(clock ticks)
- I wanna share with
you how I make my maps.
(smooth music)
Okay, I know all those
clips are super fancy,
but I need to tell you it
wasn't always this way.
I used to be very not good at making maps.
Like, look at this first map
I ever made back in 2012.
A foreign service officer in the field.
It pains me to look at
that and to hear my voice,
and I'm trying to sound
all cool and casual.
You got to start somewhere I guess.
From that time on I was 24 years old,
I poured myself into
learning AfterEffects,
the software that I used to make maps.
I devoured tutorials
and I got better and better at making maps
to tell the types of
stories I wanted to tell,
and that's what this video is.
It's sort of the result of
many, many years of refinement.
So, today what I'm gonna
do, talk a little bit
about my journey in map-making
and the evolution of my style.
And then I'm gonna dive into
two different workflows.
One is a workflow that
requires a $200 plugin,
which is expensive.
And I used to not be able to afford that.
And so, I'm also going
to teach you the workflow
that doesn't include that plugin,
a workflow that I used for years.
Even at Vox I used it for
a long time for map-making.
I don't use it anymore
because it's less efficient
but I wanna teach you both workflows,
so you have both options.
And using the workflow I use currently,
I will show you how I make
an animation like this.
(smooth music)
And all this I'm going to do
on a laptop that Intel send me.
So everyone's heard of
Intel, but this computer
that they sent me has this Evo badge on it
which is their brand
new 11th gen processor.
The major highlight of this thing
is that it is lightning fast,
it provides an insane amount of speed.
And by the way, there's
a link in my description
that you can click to go learn more about
the 11th gen processor
and Intel Evo overall.
Go click that link, support this channel,
but also teaches you a lot more
about how this stuff works.
Intel sent it to me, asked me to try out
one of my heavy workflows
on it, see how it works.
And that's what I'm gonna do.
I'm gonna take you along on the journey.
But first, storytime.
(smooth music)
So after I made that
first map back in 2012,
the next year I graduated from college,
moved to Washington DC, and
got a job at a think tank
where I made map stories for them.
That's where I really started to refine
my map making workflow
and learn how to use maps
to tell a variety of different
stories, to show data,
to show historical trends,
to draw different types of borders,
to use it as a creative tool.
And then in 2014 Vox was born
and I got rejected from Vox,
try it again, got accepted,
and then started working there.
I brought this map-making workflow to Vox,
continued to refine it as I
told all sorts of stories.
Eventually I started
going out into the field
and shooting sort of mini
documentaries using maps
to help compliment those stories.
The series, after all,
it was about borders
and I found a need to draw
really specific borders
in a really specific way
to show data in a really specific way.
And so, I had to upgrade my
whole map-making workflow.
This all came to a head in
the last season of Borders
which was Borders India,
where I had to take a bunch
of physical maps from
the partition of India
and translate them into the digital space
to tell this really
important partition story.
I tell you this whole story,
number one, because I want you to know
that I wasn't always good at maps.
I was once very bad at maps
and through a lot of practice got better.
Okay, so, there's some hope in that.
Number two, I want you to know
that there's a lot of refinement and work
that has gone into the
workflow I'm about to share.
So just know that this isn't something
I just sort of pulled out of my hat.
This is something that I've
been polishing for years.
Okay, without further ado, let's do this.
(smooth music)
So, what's fascinating to
me about this whole thing
is that for the years
that I've been developing this workflow,
I have always worked on these
like big beefy computers.
The fact that I'm sitting
here with this computer
that is a little bigger than a tablet
in terms of how light it
is and how nimble it is.
And the 11th gen processor
gives you the power
to take on this workflow is wild to me.
It's wild, and it's sort
of proving my age here.
Like I'm sort of like
the old person being like
back in my day.
So as I promised, I'm going
to show you two workflows.
The one I did for many many years
that doesn't require any plugins.
It just requires AfterEffects,
the Adobe animation program
which is a program that is
enhanced by this processor.
Then I will move on
to the one that requires the
$200 plugin called GeoLayers.
If you want to just skip to
that, to the GEOlayers part,
go to the time code that is here on screen
and you can skip to it.
But if not, let's dive in
to my original workflow.
One of the cool things here
is that Intel actually works
with Adobe to make sure
that their hardware
works most efficiently
with their software.
So they like collaborate.
My original workflow is simple.
It has to do with two main ingredients,
AfterEffects and a file called Jenkins.
This is a file that I refined for years.
It's an Illustrator file
that has all of the countries
in the world that are layered out.
Not all of them are layered
out, but a lot of them are.
And that is very high resolution,
in that you get some really nice detail
in all of these countries.
You can Command A and
get all of them selected
and you can change the stroke if you want,
if you want the borders to be
like a dark gray or something,
you can do that.
It takes a minute because,
well, it doesn't take a minute.
It, that was very fast.
This is a big file. It's
got a lot of data in it.
And this is what makes
this first workflow tick.
This is free for all of my patrons.
I have a bunch of people
on Patreon who support me.
And this is a perk that I'm
putting up right now on Patreon.
So if you want this file,
go sign up on Patreon.
Let's talk about how this
works in AfterEffects.
I want to bring this into AfterEffects.
I'll leave it open in Illustrator,
and I'll show you why in
a minute, bring it in.
And it's going to ask me right away,
do you want this to be merged
in as one piece of footage?
Or do you want to make it a composition
to have all the layers editable?
For now, I just want footage.
If you were doing something that had a lot
of different layering of countries
and you needed to make all the countries
different colors or whatever,
then you could make it a composition
because it's all layered up.
But for now, it's just
a big piece of footage.
Take that big piece of footage
and put it into a new comp.
We'll call it map the old way.
This is my old style, 1920 by 1080,
make sure this is like, you
know, three minutes or something
and you bring it right in.
Okay, this is vector.
So you can zoom in as
much as you want on this.
If this little thing is clicked, click,
let's give this thing a
background with Control Y.
I'm going to make the background
sort of like a bluish thing
like that for water.
I don't know. And now we've
got ourselves a background.
I'll put it underneath and now let's say
I want to change the color here.
You could do it two ways.
You could do it right here in Illustrator.
You could select all and change the fill,
but the easier way to do it is
just to take a hue saturation
and throw it on and start
playing with the hue saturation.
Okay. That's nice.
And again, if I wanted
to change these borders,
I could come in here,
Control A and here and here.
Make these borders all white and save.
This is happening way faster
than what I'm used to.
Okay. Anyway, next we go back.
The file is now updated.
So now I've got this thing
that I could zoom in on itself
or better yet.
I could make a null layer, new, null
and this is going to be my controller.
I will Control everything so Control.
Okay. And I will parent
this guy right here.
Again, make sure that this
has this little thing.
So it looks like a little sunshine
so that it stays nice
and high res as we zoom.
Okay. Next thing.
I'm going to take the anchor point
by holding down Y and I'm going
to put it over the country.
I want to zoom into for now.
And I'm going to hit S for
scale and start zooming
and watch what happens.
I can zoom as much as I want
and boom, it's like crystal clear.
So basically your animation, P and S
is a matter of now putting
two little keyframes,
going to where you want to go next
and going over a little
bit or going this way.
And you now animate and
maybe zoom out a little bit.
Okay. And now you've got
yourself a little animation.
Okay. You can do that anywhere in the map.
It's very simple. It
is big, giant Jenkins.
What if I want to color in Iraq?
There is a very easy way to do this.
You could either import Jenkins
with all of the layers as compositions,
and that's a different workflow.
I'm not going to go into that
but it is possible because
all the layers are layered out
in Illustrator, right here you can see.
Or my favorite thing to
do is to check this out.
Control Y, make a new solid,
and I'm gonna call it Iraq.
And this is the color of the
thing I'm going to highlight.
I'm gonna make it some orangy, something
and I'm just gonna put it over the top.
Okay. That is Iraq, but check it out.
I'm now going to go back into
Illustrator and to be safe.
I'm going to hit A, to
get the direct select tool
which is a tool that
really doesn't select,
doesn't include any of the
groupings that could be here.
None of this is, it's all
pretty cleanly pared down
but I'm going to grab
that, Control C for copy,
back to AfterEffects.
Oh, I have to have this, select it,
Control V for paste and boom.
That's actually Iraq.
Watch what happens if I scale
this sucker up, scale it up.
And now I have a mask that is Iraq,
super low res, not for long, boom.
That thing makes it
nice and crystal clear.
Now the trick is you want to make sure
that this is parented
to the same controller.
So they're all part of the same system.
So now during that little move that I did,
I want this to animate on.
So I'm going to take T, make a keyframe
and bring it out and
then start it at zero.
So it goes from zero
to a hundred over time
and you can see that as it
goes from left to right,
it animates on.
Okay. Boom.
Okay. So that is the basics.
This is how I used to do it.
I used to make so many
videos using this workflow
of zooming around using
a null and a big old file
and layering stuff on top of it.
And there was like 50 or a hundred layers.
All parented to this one controller
and it was pretty nuts, but
then I discovered GEOlayers.
And more importantly, I
could afford GEOlayers.
It is expensive, but so incredibly useful.
So let's now move on to
how we would approach
this same thing with GEOlayers,
which is really a much
more powerful workflow.
(upbeat music)
So far, candidly, 100% like honestly,
the 11th gen Evo processor is killing it.
It's actually kind of
frustrating because I have,
I'm used to working on these
big, expensive beastly machines.
And in some ways this is
outpacing them like that.
What it was doing in Illustrator
with the selection stuff,
it's almost like, wait, what?
I can get over that. I keep
going, really cool though.
Really cool that this little chip
has so much power to make these workflows
like buttery smooth in
such a teeny little thing.
So this next workflow is GEOlayers.
I'm not going to go into how
GEOlayers works fundamentally.
There are loads of wonderful
tutorials that GEOlayers itself
has put together and you
should go watch those
if you're interested
in learning the fundamentals of GEOlayers.
You'll pick up on some of them
by seeing what I'm doing here
but I'm not going to go step-by-step.
In this next workflow,
I'm going to show you how to style a map
to exactly how you want to style it.
I'm going to show you how
to set it up with GEOlayers
and to link that styling into GEOlayers,
to move stuff around,
and then to label and do
sort of what we did here
with Iraq where you can draw a country.
All of that is so much easier
in GEOlayers. Check it out.
I'm going to make a new comp
and I'm going to call
this comp map the new way.
First things first, we're
going to pull up GEOlayers.
I have it all installed, and
I'm going to go to extensions.
I'm going to go to GEOlayers.
It's going to power up.
So I'm going to hit the tilde key
in the upper left to
make this full screen.
It just makes it a lot easier
for me to see, for you to see,
for everyone to see, this
is blinking right now
because this is where
you need to click first,
create a new map comp.
A map comp is basically
a map that you can style
and move around.
I'm going to call this one Iraq map, okay?
And it will live within
the comp we just made
which was called mapping the new way.
Okay, after I hit next,
it's going to ask me what the style is.
You can license some of
this data that they have
on the GEOlayers site
or you can pick one of
their default styles
or you can do what I do,
which is go to Mapbox.
Mapbox are the people behind
a lot of the mobile apps
you use, the maps you use
for like Uber or GrubHub.
I don't know, but like
those types of maps,
Mapbox makes those, but
hack of the world is
that you can design your own maps
and not use them for an app,
but use them in GEOlayers,
check it out.
This is called Mapbox Studio
and it is free for you to use
for non-commercial purposes.
So new style coming here,
and you can choose one
of these pre-baked styles that they have.
Let's do outdoors.
The beautiful thing about this
is you can now customize it.
So outdoors is really a
nice-looking map style.
So this is just like
a sort of Google Maps.
And you can see that as I zoom,
different features come on.
Like, as I just zoomed right
now, all of these interstates
and their signs came on, all these labels.
I don't want all these
things. You may, but I don't.
I like to clean up my map.
So I'm going to go over to Iraq,
which is the place that
we are focusing on here.
And I'm going to go simply
click on a place like Baghdad
and say, place labels.
I'm going to click it. And
I'm going to say place labels.
I actually don't want to see you.
So countries, nope. States
and provinces, nope.
Settlements. Nope.
Subdivisions. None of it.
I'm also seeing these provincial borders
which I don't really want to see.
You may want to see those. I don't.
So I'm going to hit
administrative boundaries,
disputed country boundaries.
I don't know if you want
those, state and province.
Boom. That's what we don't want.
Okay. So you can start
to see the power of this.
We went from a big cluttered design
to a super clean nice design
that we can put our own labels on.
Once this is in GEOlayers.
Yes. This is going to be
in GEOlayers pretty soon.
This is ready for me to
bring into AfterEffects.
The way I do that is first
hit publish, publish.
And then I'm going to get a special code
that I'm going to use in AfterEffects.
You go up to share and warning.
This is going to look like
black magic what I'm about to do
because it's like so
buried in these menus.
You go to share, you
go over to third party.
She can go here to Cardo and
you grab this API address.
Copy it, okay? You take
this sucker over to here.
You remember where we were here?
We had made the map comp
and now it's asking us what
kind of style do we want?
We want to add a new style
and we want to paste it into
this URI code, Command V paste.
Boom. There's our map.
And I'm going to hit apply.
So now I've got this new map.
Well, I'm gonna actually
rename it to outdoor map. Okay?
I've got that big API
code. I'm gonna hit apply.
And here it is, outdoor,
beautiful and create.
And now it's doing its magic
and it is creating a comp that allows me
to see this map comp, but in AfterEffects.
Here's the deal, though.
You won't see it in high res right away.
At first, you'll see it sort of like this.
These are temporary tiles,
that it just downloads
for you to block out your
animation and start moving.
Eventually when you're
done, you'll hit finalize
and it will download
all these high res tiles
as good as you want them.
So let's talk about what
is going on in here.
You have two layers down here.
You have the map, which
that's the baseline thing.
You're never going to animate the position
or scale of this.
I'll show you what you do animate.
And then you have this anchor.
This anchor is the thing
that you anchor anything
you want to stick on the map
you parent it to this and it will stick.
And we'll get to that in a minute.
But first let's just figure
out how to move around.
The easiest way to move
around is just with this thing
over here, zoom out, and
the map comp zooms out,
zoom in and the map comp zooms in,
drag and then outcome drags,
and get ready for the best part.
Right click and drag
up. And you get a tilt.
Look at that.
Okay. You're starting to see
how I make my videos now.
This is like,
you're probably like seeing
how the sausage is made.
You're like, oh, that's how he does it.
So let's, let's do some keyframes.
I'm going to start here,
way back here and I'm going to zoom out.
I want it to start up here
and I'm going to hit this big old, oops,
I'm gonna hit this big, old
keyframe button right here.
I'm going to go forward to, you know,
seven seconds and I'm
going to zoom in to Iraq.
So I'm just going to zoom
in by scrolling, okay.
Zooms in. This isn't finalized.
So it'll look better when it's finalized.
Let's say I want it to
start wide, zoom into Iraq,
wait there for a minute and then zoom in
to a little village in the South of Iraq.
So I'm going to have it wait there
for maybe, I dunno, four seconds.
And then I am going to
look at all of these.
These are the keyframes
that run GEOlayers,
latitude, which makes it go up and down,
longitude, which makes
it go left and right,
zoom, which makes it zoom,
bearing, which watch, makes it spin,
and pitch, which makes it go down.
Okay, you can, if you're
more comfortable down here
with these, you can just
keyframe everything down here.
Instead of using this UI. I'm
going to get rid of these.
So we zoom in and I tend
to always go right onto
the keyframes and make sure
there's a keyframe everywhere.
It's going to sit for a little bit
and maybe during, while it's sitting
I'm going to have it pitch
down, just a titch like this.
Okay. Everything else
I'm going to have sit.
And now I want it to zoom
into a little village
in Southern Iraq called Basra.
It's not a village, it's a city.
It's one of the big cities in Iraq.
I could either go find
it and try to zoom in,
but here's where GEOlayers
becomes truly magical.
You can search on the internet
for addresses, for cities,
for even latitude and longitude.
And in fact, again, you can
always take this guy tilde
and get the full screen here.
I'm going to hit Basra,
B-A-S-R-A, okay, Basra.
And there it is, this is Basra in Iraq.
It says it right there.
This is data scraped from the internet.
You can do several things here.
You can make a label which
we'll do in a little bit.
You can fit view, which means it will take
where your camera is
or where you're zoomed.
And it will zoom you in to Basra.
I'm going to hit that, boom.
And now watch what happens when I go back,
hit tilde and I'm in Basra.
And because I was back here,
it did all of the latitude
and longitude for me
to the point where I'm now in Basra.
So now I have a zoom from
here all the way into Basra.
I'm going to put myself
over those keyframes
and maybe pitch down just a little bit.
Maybe do this bearing a little bit.
And maybe what I'll do
is I'll take this bearing
and I'll bring it out a
little bit so it orbits.
So this bearing is sort of coming down
and orbiting like this.
It's a little bit delayed.
The more you delay it, the
more sort of orbiting happens.
This is cool.
This is looking really, really cool
in a matter of a few minutes, okay.
Let's say I want to
highlight Iraq, label it,
and then zoom into Basra.
So first things first,
I am going to try to find a shape of Iraq.
Now you remember how we did
that with the Illustrator file
and all of that, that was very
clunky and sort of handmade.
This is a lot smoother.
So I'm gonna hit back.
It's really important that you hit back.
Cause right now, when you're
searching the internet,
you're in this sort of second
layer of the interface.
You wanna hit back to
get back to your home.
You have your search internet up here,
but then you have this hub.
This is like your data hub down here.
Again, I'm going to go
tilde and make it big.
Your data hub is where
you can put geo data sets,
which are like, GOJSONs,
that's a little advanced
if you're new to this,
but more importantly,
an example of a dataset is a country,
like how a country's shape is.
You can go here and add a
feature to this data browser.
And I want to download features
and I want to download countries.
So now it's downloading, I
now have natural earth data
for every single country in the world.
What I'm going to do is
I'm going to find Iraq
or I can just filter out
right here, Iraq boom.
There it is. And I'm going
to hit the draw feature.
Which may be cut off a little bit
if your interface is a little bit,
you need to sort of scroll to get to it.
Now, if I do that, you can
either have an animate on,
which I don't ever really use,
I like to just have it drawn
and then I can animate it myself and boom.
There it is.
What I love about this is
it comes already anchored
and like ready to roll, here it is, Iraq,
it's anchored to this anchor null,
which is really important.
And so now anything I
do, it will go with it.
Now let's make a label for Iraq generally,
you can use the label maker in here,
which I'll explore in a minute
but I also just want to show
you how I do it with text.
So I'm going to hit
Control T to get my text.
I'm going to type in Iraq.
Now, remember this
thing has to be anchored
to the Iraq map anchor,
or it won't scale with us.
It'll just stay in the middle like that.
Whereas if I do this and I bring it here,
everything, everything,
everything that you want to stick
to that needs to be anchored.
I also need to make it 3D
if I want it to respond to some of these.
Yeah. Like that.
Okay. You see now it's
totally stuck to it.
Next let's zoom in to
Basra and label Basra.
We're going to zoom in.
I'll probably want this
orange to sort of fade away
while we zoom.
So I'm going to hit T for
transparency or opacity.
And we're now in Basra.
I could either do the
text thing that I just did
or a really cool feature
is I'm going to search
Basra again, B-A-S-R-A.
And instead of having it fit
view, like I did the first time
I'm going to hit make label or add label.
Boom. And there it is, Basra.
And that Basra right there is responsive.
So I could have it as it, as
we zoom out, look at that.
It scales with the map comp in
this really cool dynamic way.
You can come here.
There's all sorts of
things you can do here
to make it react a little bit differently.
That is labeling.
So this next step is the most important
in terms of time management.
It takes time and in
terms of making sure that
your map looks beautiful.
So I'm going to hit finalize.
What that's going to do
is it's going to connect
to the server of that Mapbox
studio profile that we made.
And it's going to download little JPEGs
from the internet onto this machine.
And then it's going to
arrange them perfectly
and put expressions in the
middle, do all this stuff
so that it looks really
natural to what we animated.
It's a really magical process
and it requires good
internet or decent internet.
And it requires good processing power
because it's a lot of
calculations happening at once.
This machine has a new wifi chip
that should work great for this.
It also has the 11th gen Evo processor
that hopefully will make
this a much smoother process.
So I'm going to hit finalize
and we'll see what happens.
Okay. You can see it
downloading all these images.
It goes on to a part of your hard drive
that you can specify,
and it is placing them
into the right space in the
map comp for it to work.
It's honestly really amazing.
Oh, are we done? We're done.
Wow. That was insanely quick.
Again, this video is sponsored by Intel.
I know like, I've done this so many times.
That was very fast.
That was buttery smooth.
Again, I sort of feel like,
why have I been relying
on these insanely beefy
expensive machines?
When I pitched this idea of like,
I'm going to do my map workflow
that usually I do on
a big monster machine,
I was sort of like, can this
little laptop handle that?
And it 100% can. It can handle
it better than I thought.
So I'm very impressed
with the 11th gen Evo
processor from Intel.
And again, that's a totally
candid thing to say right now.
Like I'm actually reacting
to how well it's doing.
You can do all sorts of
stuff to style this up,
color correct, Lutz, whatever you want.
But this is the basic heart
of my mapping workflow.
Let's get this thing rendered out
and see what it finally looks like.
Now, render times are really important
for video people because they
can make or break your day.
If you have really long render
times with these animations,
you don't want to render very often.
And so you end up just guessing
and sort of doing everything
in the AfterEffects and
then doing one big render
and just like hoping that it works.
When you have faster render times,
it allows you to output sort
of a draft and say like,
I think this is pretty close to good.
You bring it in to Premiere.
You time it up.
And then if it's wrong
or if there's mistakes,
like there always are, you
just go back and you fix them
and you render out a new
one and it's like, no drama.
It's not like you're committing
to three hours of waiting.
Instead, it happens very quickly.
So here's the remaining time.
As it digests this it's going
from what was 57 minutes.
And it is just tanking by the second.
This is real time right
now what you're seeing.
It turns out if I go into
the log that that took,
in coding time six minutes and 33 seconds
to render that big beast.
That's awesome. So this
was a real experiment.
I hadn't actually used this
laptop to do this workflow
until right here in front of you all.
And I'm incredibly impressed
with the performance.
This is a small little laptop.
It fits in something that is
a little bigger than a tablet.
I mean, look at this.
And yet I was able to do my
start to finish map workflow
which is fairly processor
intensive on this thing.
And it held up just fine
while I had multiple applications open
I had the screen recording software open,
all at the same time.
The thing that makes this whole process
run so smoothly is the 11th
gen Evo processor from Intel.
This chip is a huge leap forward for Intel
and for all processors on the market.
It uses AI to actually reduce
noise in a really smart way.
So you don't have to worry
about background noise
when you're on an important call.
The chip also helps enhance audio
to make it sound richer and better.
It helps display for gaming
and for video editing.
No matter how you look at
it, whether it's streaming
or being productive in the
office or editing maps,
this chip is a powerhouse
and it enables for much faster workflows,
as I just saw right before your eyes.
There's a link in my description
where you can learn more
about the devices that have
the Intel 11th gen processor
and you can learn more about
just Intel Evo overall.
click that link and help
support this channel.
But it's also a great
place to go learn more
about this really cool,
fast, amazing processor.
The first batch of these amazing
processors inside laptops
are hitting the shelves
this holiday season.
And if you're someone who
is looking for an upgrade
in your workflows, this
is a fantastic option.
Thank you, Intel, for
supporting this channel
and supporting this video
and allowing me to make a video
I've wanted to make for a long time.
I wanted to share this
workflow with you all
for a long time.
A lot more behind the scenes
is shared on my Patreon.
If you want to go over and check that out,
thank you all for being here.
And I hope it's a happy holiday season
for those celebrating
holidays and happy New Year.
And I'll see you soon.
(upbeat music)